[Music]
this is Star Talk Cosmic qu's Edition
Neil degrass Tyson here your personal
astrophysicist I got with me Paul
Mercurio Paul welcome back to Star Talk
all right great to be back great to see
you buddy how are you all right Paul's a
professional comedian you're an Emmy and
I just learned also a Peabody Award
winner you never told me that you get an
Emmy just for being funny but you get a
Peabody Award for being funny with
Purpose with intellect with intellect
why are you laughing that I don't have
an intellect no I did no it's not no you
no no that's not why I know I no just
congratulations it's I think Peabody
we've always counted that among the
highest possible Awards someone can get
uh who's got stuff on online or on TV or
uh or in video so congratulations on
that and you perform regularly on The
Late Show with Steven colar so great to
have you here so today it's cos aquaries
and we're going to talk about
astrobiology we don't talk about that
subject enough and so we're going to
bring a returning guest Kenda Lynch
Kenda welcome back to Star Talk hi
thanks so much for having me I'm super
excited to be here excellent excellent
you're a staff scientist at the lunar
and planetary Institute the LPI just
outside of Johnson Space Center in
Planet Houston and we you're an
astrobiologist and we we have you on
primarily to talk about a new NASA
project called plant Trek now we all
know Star Trek plant Trek sounds a
little derivative but investigating
strategy wa I got the wait I got the the
the the line here investigating
strategies for regolith
preconditioning to esort support
establishment of plant microbe systems
in Martian habitats I wrote that by the
way I wrote that that English you're
welcome K you're welcome oh thank you
Paul thank you so kenet don't ever
repeat that phrase on this show ever
okay just what the hell is a rolith I
think I know but it sounds like you've
been hanging out with geologists too
long so let's let's give us in plain
English what plant Trek is and what your
relationship is to the project what
we're trying to do with pran is we're
trying to figure out how to live on Mars
and grow on food on Mars using
in se2 resources or basically March and
regali we can't call it dirt or soil
because it doesn't have microbes in it
that we know of so anything that doesn't
have life in it is reguli that we Define
in the geology geological terms as
reguli and so Martian wait so so your
roots are in biology astronomy or
geology or all of the above I wear a lot
of hats so my actual bachelor's degrees
I have two because I'm crazy and I got
two at University of Illinois at the
same time my bachelor's degrees are in
um engineering and biology and I
designed my secondary field in
engineering to focus on what's called
Advanced life support systems so back
when I was doing engineering and I was
an engineer I learned about how to
develop life support systems for
astronauts and back then we were talking
about something called bioregenerative
life support systems or Clos Loops life
support systems ways to basically take
Earth with us and recycle of things use
plants to help us make air help us clean
our water without needing a supply ship
without needing a supply ship or any
kind of resupply because relying on a
two-year turnaround for resupply from
Earth is going to really suck if you're
living on Mars you don't want to have to
do that I mean
that's okay all right now these are now
these are tools and things so how does
astrobiology relate to this well that's
an interesting thing that I discovered
and I am and you asked about my
relationship to it I am the principal
investigator this is um one of the
projects I got funded yes I'm the pi I
got this funded with NASA to test this
process that me and my colleagues came
up with and wait so so your Pi so it is
your fault that it has that
title yes but we just call it plant Trek
and yes there's a T-shirt and you should
have my logo somewhere can I just
propose this I work at CBS I think this
is a drama it's called regul regalii pi
and then you show
up good one you got a shovel and a hat
and a thing and then there's a plant
soth so when I reach into the soils of
Earth there well I don't see it but it
is teeming with microbes that millions
and millions of microbes that have made
that soil possible yes that enables
plant life to grow in it so if I go to
the Moon I can still grab up a handful
of dirt or on Mars but there's no
microbes in it so you don't call it dirt
no we don't call it Earth we call it
regulus because it because dirt and we
don't even you know and if you talk to a
soil scientist they hate the dword they
don't like it called dirt they like it
to be soil I've learned this from my
colleague who soil scientist soil they
call it the d word I didn't know dirt
was a four-letter word but apparently
for this it is wow wow okay okay so now
what so tell me how H how astrobiology
fits in well astrology fits in because
one of the things that we learned is
that you know Mars what we know from all
of our missions to both the moon and
Mars is that the lunar regolith and the
Martian regolith have a lot of
interesting things in them they have a
lot of like heavy metal they have a lot
of iron they have a lot of um lunar soil
has a lot of titanium Martian soil has a
lot of iron and sulfur the big thing
about Mars is we have a thing called
perchlorate in it and perorate is
something that there's more of it in
Martian regular than there is on the
highest site on Earth um which would be
the Atacama Desert and perorate is a
really cool molecule that does cool
things that we like to use it for space
flight like to mail solid rocket engines
wait wait the highest spot on earth is
Mount Everest so what do you mean the
aacom the highest concentration of
perorate is in highest not the highest
elevation yeah no the highest
concentration I am sorry because the
atacoma desert is a very high elevation
we have telescopes there for that reason
so that I was confused there okay thank
you for clarifying it is the highest
concentration of prorate because it is
one of the driest places on the planet
and perchlorate um accumulates natural
proc chlorate is raining actually all
over out all over the planet all the
time it's generated in the atmosphere
using photochemistry with ozone it it a
pH photochemistry reactions with ozone
make per chlorate and it rains out all
over the planet wait wa wait so what is
the what is the whole molecule per
chlorate it's got at least chlorate it
has got one little um um chlorine atom
in the m in the center surrounded by
four big oxygen atoms oh it's only
chlorine and
oxygen I didn't know that okay yeah it's
very simp come on Neil everybody knows
that come on Neil I I can't work like
this
L he's always I'm sorry he's always
playing katchup on this stuff okay all
right so per chlorate I gotta so so
ozone gets you three oxygen molecules
for free okay and so and and how many
total is surrounding the chlorine four
so four for per chlorate and there's
another one call chlorate it's just
three but we kind of focus on Pro
chlorate right now because that's the
that's the big one that that that we
care about the most right now and why is
that important um because for a couple
of reasons first of all um it's
important for humans because for
likes is an is a contaminant that
affects human health per chlorate is the
perfect size to compete with iodine for
binding on your thyroid so if you have
perchloride in your system it's going to
knock that iodine out of the way and
bind to your thyroid and guess what your
thyroid is not GNA work too good our
bodies are just so stupid they can't
figure out what they don't know basic
chemistry right right right so it's just
it's got the right Affinity where it
just likes to knock the iodine away so
if you're eating let's say if you're
eating eating Martian potatoes that were
grown Martian dirt like Matt Damon did
right we didn't get those are poop
potatoes they are po potatoes but
remember he he he he planted them in the
ground in Mars an actual Mars regul
ground which there would have been proc
chlorate in those in those regulates
even though he mixed it with poop he
didn't take care of the proc chlorate so
if he had eaten those poop potatoes
other than the fact that they're poop
potatoes he would have been ingesting
prorate like all the time because
prorate is so mobile it would have
actually been uptaken probably into the
potato bottom line is if he'd eaten
those potatoes we would have killed Matt
Damon oh also the idea that like it a
group of people in all seriousness
couldn't eat those potatoes because the
poop has his pathogens in it which would
be fine for him but wouldn't work for
others exactly there are some other
issues with regards to the PA I know
this because as a hobby I freeze dry my
waist just as a hobby but the point is
that in all seriousness it would not
have worked as a concept okay because
not without some bior remediation which
is one of the things that we try to do
when we develop what we call biological
life support bior regenerative life
support systems we remediate things we
try to clean up things and make them
safe before we use them to grow our food
and the first thing we're trying to do
with plant trk is we're trying to deal
with this big El this big Chlor proc
chlorite elephant in the room which is
what do we do with the fact that there
is up to 1% in some cases 2% weight by
weight for chlorate in the Martian
regulus and if we're going to use that
regolith to help us grow food we need to
figure out what to do with eper
chlorates wa wait the Moon is as at
least as dry as Mars why doesn't the
moon have the same amount of per
chlorate in it well that is a good
question it's probably because first of
all the moon doesn't really have an
atmosphere and so prorate on Mars is
probably also there's a lot of chlorine
on Mars because of all the vulcanism on
Mars so there's a lot more chlorine on
Mars and there was a lot of you know
volcanism from from long ago from long
ago but still put a lot of chlorine on
there and we're not sure if it's not
quite the same process because there's
not a lot of ozone on Mars right but we
thought we think it's more surface grain
chemistry or other kind of chemistry
maybe even when when there was um you
know surface of groundwater that made
that proc chlorate Pro probably the
biggest theory is probably surface type
grain chemistry Al along with radiation
like impacting it causing like surface
chemistry happening radiation you mean
uh high energy light from the sun yes
yeah high energy photons hitting all the
high energy photons coming in just
question there was a there was a an
experiment done in China in Laboratories
with lunar soil where they grew a
certain question a certain sh of tobacco
and just a long question okay and and
would they and is that tobac is that
experiment was that experiment able is
that any help that we've gotten from
that for what you're doing in terms of
what they were they they used three
forms of bacteria to grow this sort of
strain of tobacco anything from that
study that helps um it it does because
it's interesting because there's a lot
of different um yes and no so no on the
fact that we're really not going to try
to encourage tobacco use on the moon or
Mars no I know Paul that new story for
the type of plant that they chose
nicotine addicts on Mars what you well
listen you're gonna have a cigarette
stand everywhere so why not Paul but but
from the standpoint of that they tried
different bacteria to try to improve the
lunar regolith and to try to create um a
good Community with the regolith yes
that was very helpful I've I've seen
that study um and um we're starting to
move into some of the lunar regolith
work too but right now one of our first
things with plant Trek and what we were
funded to do is kind of solve that for
chlorate issue and and the reason
astrology ties in is because one of the
things that I realized when I started
thinking about life support systems with
my colleagues again and things is that I
learned so much about extreme
environments and extreme microbes and I
actually happen to have this
2019 uh astrobiology paper where we
discovered for chlorate reducing
microbes in a Mars analog environment
you know happened to have that and I was
like you know what if we microbes from
that environment and applied it to you
know and test it and see if we could
take you know um Martian simulant that
we pre-loaded with simulated with proc
chlorate and we simulated actual Mark
and reguli what if we took those bugs
out of that environment and put them in
Martian reguli to see if they could
process all that proc chlorate out and
hence plant trunk was born this is a
tiny part of the Cog in the wheel of
terraforming isn't it
it you're using the t- word the t- word
I'm
saying if you want to make Mars good
enough for you know for prime time you
got to fix everything up you got it you
got you need until you can put your
microbes to work you can have a microbe
cocktail you set it Loose some will
produce the ozone others will take out
the perchlorate others will make the
soil whatever others will poop where you
need it with the right kind of poop not
not Paul's poop Paul's poop won't grow
anything Neil Neil I'm glad you're
getting excited but I need to rank
really in because we got this whole
thing called planetary protection and we
don't want to do that yet because we're
still trying to find out if Mars has its
own life on it but we do want to be able
to support human life we don't want to
kill our mat Damons we want to keep our
matons alive so so we do want to try to
figure out ways to use inc2 resources
because like I said that supply chain
issue of two years that's Ser it's even
worse than the pandemic also you should
stay in the character and call him Mark
Watney okay
just I'm just saying we've had Andy Weir
as a guest on Star Talk and he would
want you to call him Mark Watney fair
enough Mark Watney we don't want to kill
our Mark
Watney introducing the all electric Ford
Mustang Mach SUV Ford is electrified
buying its icons to keep the sole of
driving alive while shifting towards an
electric vehicle future the Mustang Mach
e is an SUV with the Bold style of a
Mustang which means you can make a bold
statement and still be practical the
2023 Mustang Mach e GT performance
Edition SUV achieves 0 to 60 mph in 3.5
seconds it's an EV with exhilarating
torque and available features like
electric all-wheel drive and a drive
mode called unbridled it has room for
you your people and your things with
five seats and a front otherwise known
as a front trunk experience the freedom
and Thrill of the drive while knowing
your needs can still be met learn more
about the all electric Ford Mustang ma
SUV at
ford.com SUVs SL moach hyen e due to
high demand and Global Supply Chain
constraints some models Trims and
features may not be available or may be
subject to change check with your local
dealer for current information for the 0
to 60 mph in 3.5 seconds Ford test data
is based on a typical industry
methodology using one foot rollout your
results May Vary so Paul this is a
cosmic queries and you've got question
for I do yeah we're gonna Jump Right In
Here I haven't seen them I don't think
kenda's seen them and so no I haven't
seen a single thing so Kenda
occasionally they drift into the
universe I'm happy to take those if you
if it's like drifts away from your
planet expertise but otherwise they're
all for you so let's let's go well this
first one's appropriate based on what we
were just talking about so this is from
Dennis greetings humans this is Dennis
from Indiana Dr Lynch you were you ever
approached by filmmakers for technical
support when they were shooting the the
Martian no that's a good question but no
I was still in grad school when they
were shooting the Martian so
no okay but if they were shooting it
today you no reason why you wouldn't be
on their list yeah if they were shooting
today I would give tech support any day
of the week that would be that would be
fun yeah but then you would have ruined
the Poop Potato you say that can't
happen cut cut you would have had a big
fight with Ridley Scott there would have
been right oh just have a Duke out with
Ridley Scott that's a I'm just saying I
gave technical advice on the movie on
how to kill any living plant known to
man ever so I'm that guy so uh I can't
grow airplants okay that's how bad I am
I mean they even skipped over the whole
planetary protection issue about
wondering about life on MAR I mean there
were so many things astrology relevant
skipped over yeah but but you know you
sit next to my friends who were both a
planetary geologists and then you know a
you know a flight systems engineer when
I went to go see the movie and all of us
were going nope nope on different parts
of the
movie but we had fun we thought it was
fun it was the closest movie that got
close to you know accurate see on the
science and the engineering so we love
it we have fun we loved it science was
its own character in that film it was it
really it for that and that's the film
that's the film where science became a
verb there you go I'm gonna science the
out of this I'm GNA science the out
of this right two science that's what
Matt D UT in the film okay science what
else you got Paul okay Andy Weber hey Dr
Tyson Dr Lynch and Dr Mercurio wow thank
you oh all right I just added that this
is Andy I gonna say he got an honorary
PhD from yeah from from The Daily
Show this is Andy from Edmonton Alberta
I'm a big fan of the movie The Martian
and in that movie Mark Watney see he did
it right is able to plant potatoes on
Mars using Martian dur water in human
ways would this be possible uh how could
this be more realistic thank you so much
love the show so let's unpack that so so
we we are told that solid excrement is
fertilizer that's an entire cottage
industry in the farming Universe for
just that so let me ask you what's the
difference between human poop and horse
poop all right for in terms of
fertilizer second what does the borate
matter if he's completely embedded
the the
potato seeds or the eyes of the potato
in poop then why do the rest of the
prorate matter well so okay so let's
unpack that completely so first um the
difference between per poop and like
horse poop well horses eat a lot more
grass and a lot more like vegetarian
diet whereas humans tend to eat meat and
other things so no no just get the poop
of vegetarian humans that's
not no matter no matter what do you know
how annoying that poop would
be
oh my God itd be looking down its nose
at the other poop oh everywhere from the
vegetarian no that's the vegan poop that
would have right right right the vegan
poop well of course you of course
percolate is a problem for you because
you're not a vegan
poop so how do you make how do you make
the the the mark Watney scenario work I
think in the end that's what we really
want to know I mean so how we make the
the scenario work is how we do things
here on Earth we do we we add a few more
things in between the poop and and and
the plants that make the whole Loop
right so we get the plant we get the
poop and we process it a little bit we
get the right microbes eating it that
microbes that are making things that we
like like you know like night you know
nitrates and things like that that we
want to put in the soil we get that th
there and then we can then turn and we
make sure we get rid of the the microbes
the bugs that could make people sick or
like could kill our helpful bugs because
there are unhelpful bugs that take over
and we don't want that so we want to
make make sure that we have a good
microbial we want to make sure we have a
good poop microbiome just because this
microb will do task a and this microb
will do task B doesn't mean a plus b
will work because a could eat B is what
you're saying well yeah and we and we
want to make sure that we have a good
population of a A through Z that are
going to be happy and keep like if a is
the bad guy that could really make a
human sick we want a under control a is
always going to be there I mean like for
example ecoli is everywhere you know the
kindergarten joke why was six afraid of
seven
because it because 78 n yes CU
789 that's that's like safe for
kindergart right right yes if you got
microbes you don't want microbes eating
other microbes if they all have a task
or just taking over and taking all the
re what they do is they may not eat the
other microb but they may be like see
all these resources they're all mine and
then they deny it from the other
microbes and the other microbes die of
starvation so you don't want that you
can't genetically modify some of these
microbes to make them what you want them
to be we can but we we're going we're
you know we can and there are folks that
work on that we're trying to but
microbes are pretty smart every time we
think we got microbes understood they go
yeah here fold my beer watch this you
know so every time we think we got them
understood but they're pretty smart and
they know how to organize themselves in
a way to be optimal for the environment
they're in so we're trying to learn at
least on plant Trek we're trying to
learn how microbes from an extreme
environment like how could they organize
themselves in a in a in a Mars simulated
environment how could they organize
themselves to deal with perorate in a
simulated environment so that's what we
want to try to do okay so to get back to
this unpack question is yeah we want we
want to use that poop that poop is good
it's got nutrients we just want to make
sure that we control we we get the we
get the rough guys under control and we
put them back in and then um we want to
make sure and the reason that the
prorate still matters is if you saw um
Mark Watney still put the potatoes in
the ground where that regula still had
perorate in it and perorate is super
mobile it goes wherever water water is
it's really water soluble so you put in
water it's wherever the water goes it's
going to go so if you put if you water
your potatoes and there is proc in the
regul it's going to dissolve into the
water and it's going to get uptaken by
the roots of the potatoes and then get
concentrated in the potatoes you don't
want that and I just was reminded I
reminded myself of the periodic table of
elements where elements that appear in a
vertical column have similar external uh
similar electron configurations in their
outermost shell which means they make
similar families of molecules to each
other so an iodine is right there below
chlorine in its own in their column
exactly so wherever iodine goes chlorine
can go and there right and that's why
they have the similar affinities and
that's why it can just kind of go excuse
me iine and knock it out of the way
right right and we don't want that
because then you're gonna be hypo
thyroids and you're going to be tired
and lethargic and you know things are
going to be bad you can get you can
generate heart disease if you have low
thyroid there's a lot of negative
effects of low thyroid and if you have
chronically low thyroid it can lead to
really bad stuff including the Big D
word
[Laughter]
dirt we can't have two dwords in one
show that are different too much stick
with one dword okay fair
enough are there any insects in in the
that trans that translate to Mars that
we can use like insects here that could
s got microbes if you have microbes you
don't need insects yeah right mic hugely
microscopic objects that are you know
microbes would do everything for you
right well ideally right now we're kind
of focusing on microbes I mean and and
insects are are again it's another typ
of things like insects or I mean on
Earth um you know earthworms are very
much a part of soil right but you know
we have and there are those that have
worked on trying to add earthworms to
like lunar and Martian regolith but it
takes a lot of work to keep them alive
and you have to add them a little later
after you've kind of already
pre-processed the reguli with like
microbes first but then you can
eventually add like earthworms and
things like that to to to the regali to
kind of help them get that regali going
into soil right but again that's part of
part of the terraforming I'm telling
yeah let's
just we're gonna keep it in the habitat
for now we're gonna try to keep in the
habitat so that the astrobiologist can
still look for Life on Mars outside the
habitat right all right we're gonna try
to keep it in the habitat for now so
Paul give me more yeah this is the
artist formerly known as James Smith
hello all James from Indianapolis here
so Kenda in the movie rival what do you
think the best course of action would
have been had they given someone with
your knowledge and background uh when
when the aliens showed up thanks have a
great day okay so there two arrival
movies one of them had Charlie Sheen I
think back in the 90s and that I think
they probably mean the more recent one
uh where the aliens put these vertical
ships around the world and then they got
and they got a
physicist and a linguist mhm it did and
I would have picked and I tweeted this
and I I got jumped all over because
first social media Suess poool second
you know how often how often do
linguists ever get portrayed in movies
right I said instead of a linguist and a
and a and a physicist they should have
had an astrobiologist and a
cryptographer that's what I said all
right and but then I then I felt bad cuz
you know give the some some you know cut
them Cas and shade on the linguist so
what would you have done in that case
well as a scientist with astrology cred
I would have said let me go take samples
and listen to the linguist they're
figuring something
out wait wait take samples you'd go up
to the septo Pod and then say excuse me
let me cut some of your flesh away so I
caniz it in my just do a little swab can
you just can I just swab can I just swab
one of your like tentacles that's all is
like can I swab your tentacles that's
all I would have done open the side of
your head and I want to swab you know
swab I just would want to yeah that's
all I want to do or give me some of that
ink or what you're drawn with right how
about that or just swap the spaceship I
would have just taken some spot the
spaceship and just yeah for those who
didn't see the film aliens arrived in
these pods all around the world I don't
know how many locations there were and
we focused on the one that landed in the
United States there might have been
several in the United States I don't
remember and of course the military is
there
and they got a Corin it off and we learn
that these aliens to them time is a loop
rather than a linear thing and so so and
they play with your your head about that
about right events that happened either
before or after but if time is a loop
there is no before or after there just
is right and so so that's that's where
they tried to take that yeah well and
they and they did a lot of interesting
thing about um there was a other
underlying message about common language
and commonness and and understanding and
communication being key which when we're
talking about searching for for
intelligent life which is something we
do do in astrology we look for techn
signatures techn signatures we try to
look for signs of intelligent life
either in the past especially if we're
getting signatures from hundreds of
light years away we know that that that
happened you know in the past that
Civilization may not be there anymore
but and we and we try to look for any
kind of signs of like techn you know
techn signatures even I would say nearby
but not you know they actually for the
first time commissioned that that that
committee on what is it uae's
unexplained uh
events yeah U UAP UAP is unexplained
aial phenomena right so we're actually
starting to re to think about you know
from a policy perspective maybe we're
not alone anymore you know so maybe
people are starting to think about that
from that perspective and that is
something that we do have
astrobiologists that think about that um
so like I said I I would have I would
have been all about getting samples and
trying to understand their you know
their microbiome or you know their
genetics or lack thereof like what are
they made of how did they come to be so
here we are talking about swabbing the
aliens so we can study it whereas in the
film nope which was like a alien horror
film basically the alien is sucking
people up from Earth and while it never
says it explicitly it's pretty clear
they're getting eaten it's a giant
jellyfish kind of thing just eating it
and like digesting them gesting you
while you're in its in its digestive
canal and so in that case it is swabbing
us just right just taste taking a little
taste and you know certain things it
didn't like it would spit back out right
spit back out back out but it begs the
question it answers the question that we
are not alone in the universe there are
other humans because if they like humans
and that's what they eat how did they
survive until they got to us to eat us
right so they had to be eating they were
just unhappy campers eating lesser food
that's all they chicken or fish they
didn't care they go either
way or you know deer wolves Bears
whatever they're too gy humans and plump
well they were eating horses for a while
it seemed like in the show they were
eating a lot of a lot of horses I love
that kend would just go into the ship
and just start like getting samples from
people and it's like and and they'd be
like see this is why the humans are a
little bit annoying they just come right
in and they just take over as opposed to
like at least chitchatting for a minute
before you start taking swab you kind of
liking myself to Grace from Avatar like
she's like I need to get samples
wherever she is you know right right if
you're a scientist yeah there's a
there's a there's a fun science comic
where someone you know connects these
two electrodes and there's a spark and
they get shocked and they said boy I'm
never doing that again and then another
person comes up connects them they get
sparked and said wow I wonder if that
happens every
time that's the scientist
I pull keep going all right this is this
is Captain James Riley C greetings from
Houston I was wondering what percentage
of Mars soil regolith rock is seeming to
work best in your soil mixes for healthy
plants and what kind of composition are
we dealing with uh with Mars Rock powder
I suppose you won't have uh to
supplement iron really good question and
let me just add to that that what um
Kenda remind me which Mission
intentionally landed at the boundary
between the
receding ice cap and Phoenix Mission the
Phoenix Mission so that one is finding
Martian regolith soils that are right
that are damp and maybe there's some
action there right that's a that's
that's a place that's a place and uh and
the captain duly noted that Mars has way
more iron than the moon does
right and which gives it its Rusty color
I think right yeah because it gets it
gets oxidized from that like I said that
that that radiation like the surface is
very oxidized because of the the heavy
you know the heavy you know radiation
particles and things like that that's
where we get that red color from Iron
wind Sol wind yeah from that yes okay so
great Frank Sinatra movie by the way St
by the way Frank solar wind but anyway
go ahead so to answer this question
great question that's the beautiful
thing is that Martian regulus has so
many beautiful things that we love it it
has that iron so we don't need iron it
has sulfur it actually has you know it
has it has a little bit of organic
carbon but it also has carbonates um has
a little bit of nitrates like um
biologically available nitrogen as
nitrates not a lot but it has nitrogen
in its atmosphere which is good um we
have a lot of other elements we have
some phosphorus we have we have all
these other elements that we need um and
it does have a little bit of oxygen what
do we do with phosphorus cuz the my my
first encounter with phosphorus was like
phosphorus bombs right and so oh we need
need phosphorus for our health what is
it doing in our body it's the part of
the DNA backbone phos the phosphate
backbone is fundamental to to the
creation of DNA
stupid
okay
okay okay so now I'm caught up I'm all
caught up now so if someone says you
have no backbone they're saying you have
no phosphate that's what they're saying
yeah your phosphate your your phosphorus
depleted depleted yeah I got you um so
yeah has a lot of the different it has
like the the choms or spanch it has like
a lot of the different things it has
hydrogen it has all those things from a
minerological standpoint from the actual
regali like the rock it's in the Rock we
have lots of clay We like clay in Earth
we actually have Clay in Earth and
because clay helps do a lot of things
clay has activated surfaces so it lets
things bind to it and does cat eye
exchange cat eye exchange is very
important in soil for for plant growth
um clay absorbs water it can hang on to
water so it can you know Clays swell
when they have water so they're very
good for water retention in the soil so
that that water so we don't have
overwatering and we don't drown our
plants but then we have an access to
water that the plants can take take from
a period of time and then we also have
um believe it or not and I'm still not
quite sure why this works I'm assuming
it's the calcium but gypsum there's
actually here on Earth they actually to
help certain um soils um certain um
plots of Agriculture improve their
growth yield they will actually like go
out and lay out gypsum and add and
supplement the gypsum I think has
something to do with the calcium
supplementation and the calcium and the
sulfate and the sulfate probably gets
used by microbes but the calcium is an
essential element that the that plants
need and so those two those two um
minerals are two things that we have in
abundance on Mars and remind me gypsum
is is that the softest item on that on
that hardness scale you know what I
don't remember my minerology very well
because I didn't I didn't take it
officially I I'm a Justin Time learner I
learned my minerology well if you don't
remember that why is anything you say we
should take anything you
say because I do have degre and biology
and
engineering and environmental
microbiology time for just a couple more
yeah let's see what we can Mary Lee
Dewey this is the subject I've been
waiting for I'm a high school biology
teacher and this discussion comes up a
lot we've been studying the Millay
experiment my question is what do you
think is the actual probability our
atmosphere could be recreated on another
planet like
[Music]
artificially like artificially like I
I'm trying to understand I think I think
I understand I if we catch people up on
the Miller and Yuri experiment so yeah
so Miller and Yuri too they both chemist
one may have been a biologist working at
the University of Chicago this is back
in the late 50s early 60s they put a
mixture of certain base ingredients that
we expected to find on Earth they put in
what we think was the early atmosphere
on Earth and they put a spark across
that air which as an energy source then
they went away and came back and when
they came back they found amino acids
formed spontaneously in that in that
primordial soup basically that they were
creating and so again this is very
terraforming like so I think the
question is can we set something loose
that will then create the atmosphere we
now know in Love on Earth but on another
planet so there's there's a couple
problems that that that that that my
terraform friends sometimes don't
remember and that's that Mars does not
have a a magnetic Shield anymore we
don't have the our we don't have an
electromagnetic we don't have a a Dynamo
anymore so we don't have that electro
magnetic radiation protection so um our
atmosphere is being constantly Stripped
Away
so I I'm not I'm not 100% conf confident
that we could do that but there are a
lot of concepts for how we'd have to
basically build up the atmosphere and
how we'd have to like get things in the
atmosphere to really kind of um to get
to get some some warmth and to basically
get some more radiation there's there's
a bunch of different concepts out there
so this amounts to geoengineering and
it's geoengineering you got engineering
chops so this should be right up your
alley yeah I mean from a theoretical
standpoint is it possible to I don't
know if we need to go all the way back
to Ur what we need to do is we need to
basically kind of make a simulated
greenhouse effect we need to get
something in there to kind of get a
controlled runaway greenhouse effect
where we get enough of an atmosphere in
there where we get enough heating from
from the Sun into that atmosphere where
it generates heat and and you know
thickens up the atmosphere on Mars and
then we then we can actually have you
know then we pump out some more oxygen
and things like that so it it is
possible we can get a space pipeline
from all of our energy generating plants
and pump all the CO2 to Mars there you
go and then but Mars already has CO2 in
his atmosphere but it would increase the
concentration and then yeah that's how
you do that and then Elon Musk and Jeff
Bezos can fight to see who controls the
pipeline that would be that would be the
rest of that can you explain to me what
the plan is to deal with the radiation
on like so let's say we can grow
something that supports life what do you
do have you thought about I assume you
have the the effects of radiation on
whatever you grow and how do you how do
you protect that so the big thing that
we look at is we look at habitat we look
at habitats we look at building habitats
including like a marshan like a martian
like greenhouse and those habitats would
be would have some level of some level
of shielding to manage to protect from
the radiation especially from things
from the solar Ren gcrs things like that
um one of the things that they looked at
they're looking at building partial
habitats they're looking at like Martian
you know Mars has caves they have
possible Lava Tubes they're looking at
you know or places where we just very
you know we use actually some of the
Martian regalian hide yeah to hide yeah
to kind of use it to kind of shield from
all that radiation but basically you
just kind of part of part of that is you
build that shielding into the plan the
other part is we look at how we we look
at studies about how much radiation do
we really need to Shield the greenhouse
like how much radiation before the plant
it really does you know cause plants to
grow in a way that's not healthy and
doesn't produce actual you know
nutritious nutritious biomass and things
like that so so that we can optimize we
can optimize how much shielding do we
really need for the greenhouse versus
like the hab where that humans are
sleeping if the greenhouse can take more
radiation we bet maybe don't make the
green houses shielded you know so those
are some of the the trades that we need
to look at all if if I'm going to Mars
I'm I'm bringing a satchel full of
cheeseburgers that's
all I'm
sorry and and potatoes grown in the
right poop for the right poop my own
damn poop your own poop a fry later to
your fry your potatoes grown in my own
damn poop that would be the that would
be that would be the advertisement on
Mars potatoes grown in my own damn poop
well and then you have to grow the
soybean oils to like make the soybean
oil for frying your potatoes too in your
own
poop there it's just it's just like it's
your own poop cycle right now you're
getting the vegans aroused with that old
soyan oil
stuff should we go on another yeah yeah
give me like one more all right kby hide
hello Dr and Kobe from Colorado my
question is what Kenda we can get two
more if you answer this in half the time
so let's try fair enough go hello Dr
Tyson Kobe hi from Colorado my question
is what is the coolest part about being
an astrobiologist which I guess would be
for Kendo what is the coolest part yeah
and Kenda by the way astrobiology is a
field that has no
data let me just be clear about that
well uh if you're talking
about you're talking about our ultimate
that's not true we have uh we have
ambiguous data from biking that's not
true oh it's still ambiguous data just
say it depends on how you define data Dr
Tyson and then it just creates a big
open-ended answer I just want to make it
clear there's an entire field of study
out there that has the name of something
it has yet to find yeah but here's what
it you sound like my field of expertise
has data and yours
doesn't that's what you sound like you
sound like a six-year-old he's just
jealous he's just jealous because we're
getting all the funding right now that's
all they are are totally getting all the
funding um what I love about astrology
is I get to go all over the world and
meet totally new crazy microbes and
learn the extent of amazing things that
life can figure out how to do and I just
think it's amazing that we don't even
fully understand life here on Earth and
I think that's a fun part of my job I
think you're being modest I think the
best part of your job is looking down
your nose at anybody's garden and going
really you
tomato really well let me show you my
tomato boom I grew this using Mouse
feces and some french fries from
McDonald's beat that
buddy I grew I grew that on the q line
in Manhattan beat
that all right one more what last one
real fast all right uh I'm I'm gonna do
the best with this name it's bo b Dear
Mr doctors Neil and Kenda uh this
gentleman's or Bo boot TB from nce south
of France what kind of interesting
feature could we bring from a plant
grown on Mars and brought back to Earth
could it be genetically more resilient
to low Lum Luminosity for example oh
nice so let me broaden that and then you
still have to answer it in half the time
could studying Life on Mars benefit life
on Earth 100% and give me your best way
that could happen because we're having
climate change here we're killing our
soil here on Earth and we're going to
have to figure out how to in order to
have food security we're going to have
to figure out ways to kind of help soil
grow whether it's open air or if we have
to make our own giant green houses where
we where we basically process soil like
we do on Mars to keep it healthy so we
keep growing plants so we have food
security what you're saying is if we can
grow plants on Mars nothing can stop us
from growing plants anywhere on Earth we
can keep our a okay 100% well that's all
the time we have for it you did two
within one one question thank you two
two and each and half the time Kenda
thanks for being back on Star Talk been
a delight to have you and Kenda let me
say I think you're doing great work
despite the fact that your area of
expertise has no data I think you great
way don't you let anybody undercut you
young lady you're strong you're powerful
you're
data lacking but other than that you're
like a sixth grader I know you are but
what am
I all right all right Paul good to have
you man yeah always fun this has been
another installment of Star Talk Cosmic
quaries the poop
Edition don't say dirt whatever you
do all right I Neil theg grass Tyson as
always beating you to keep looking
[Applause]
[Music]
out